this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman meanwhile
sad news beepers monkey yeah by the way
great band saw them at the troubadour
last weekend
Bieber's monkey is now officially a
citizen of Germany the monkeys are too
boy experimenting in order to make it a
super monkey yeah bionics yeah he left
his monkey in Germany like we do in
Munich at the airport they stopped and
they said this monkey can without his
papers kids are your papers they love
their [ __ ] papers those Germans yeah
give him papers yeah they put a little
banana shaped star on his chest and it
was the [ __ ] 40s come on really
geez all right Schindler he left it
behind though they said you can come
back and pick it up when your way out of
the country feel free to stop by and
pick up Molly your monkey yeah what if
Molly's named after the drugs out of the
monkey the monkey juice yeah he's good
makes you high you could [ __ ] up on
Molly so he never came back for it and
now the monkey belongs to Germany now
were they gonna do put him in a zoo they
said no because they're afraid that if
they if people find out justin bieber's
monkeys in a zoo that deranged Bieber
fans will come to the zoo and molest the
monkey because it's Bieber's and I mean
molest by you know throwing [ __ ] at them
and stuff no I don't mean like this kind
of molester so they're gonna put it in a
primate rescue facility Oh of which I'm
sure just litter Germany with tons of
those I'm sure there's a lot of apes are
running around so like he's the only one
in there that's right and it's less a
reserve and more
unuse the boxcar that's what we're gonna
put it in could you imagine your this
monkey and you're just like holy [ __ ]
man I got stripped from my [ __ ]
parents now I belong to this [ __ ]
now his dick had abandoned me in Germany
right
I hate be in this monkey he's only 20
weeks old oh [ __ ] man which luckily for
him is old enough to drink in Germany so
he's going to have a great Oktoberfest
[Music]
you
[Music]